so what we have here is a circle with
the center at point o and then we have a
tangent line to the circle and let me
actually label this line let's call this
line l
and we see at point a is the point that
the tangent line intersects with the
circle and then we've drawn a radius
from the center of the circle to point a
now what we want to do in this video is
prove to ourselves that this radius and
then this tangent line intersect at a
right angle we want to prove to
ourselves that they intersect at a right
angle and the first step to doing that
is we're going to feel good we're going
to prove to ourselves that point a
is the closest point on line l
to the center of our circle so i want to
prove
that point a
is closest
closest
point
on l
to
.0
2.0 and i encourage you to pause the
video and see if you can if you can
prove that to yourself
well to think about that just think
about any other point on line l pick any
other arbitrary point on line l it could
be this point right over here it could
be this point right over here could be
this point right over here and you
immediately see that it sits outside of
the circle and if it's sitting outside
of the circle i'll pick this point here
just so it'll become a little bit
clearer on our diagram if it's sitting
outside of the circle in order to get
from point o to this point i'll call
this point b right over here
you have to
you have to go the length of the radius
and then you have to go some more
so this length the length of segment ob
is clearly going to be longer than the
length of the radius because you have to
go to the radius to get to the the to
get to the circle itself and then you
have to go a little bit further for any
point that sits outside of the circle so
point a is the only point by definition
this is a tangent line it's the only
point that sits on the circle every
other point on line l sits outside of
the circle
so it's going to be further so point a
hopefully this makes you feel good
because you pick any other point it's
going to sit outside of the circles you
have to go the radius and then sum so
hopefully this makes you feel good that
point a is the closest point on l to the
center of the circle
now we're not done yet we now have to
convince ourselves
that if we have a point and a line that
the segment connecting the point to the
closest point on the line to to that
original point that that's going to be
perpendicular to the line so let me give
ourselves some space here
we want to prove
that if we that the
segment
connecting
a
point off the line
off the line
and closest point on the line
closest point
on the line
is perpendicular
is perpendicular to the line
so what we want to do is we want to say
hey if we have some line here
if we have some line here l and if you
were to take a point off the line
so let's say
so you wanted a point off the line so
let's say that that's this point right
over here
point o
and you want the segment connecting the
point off the line to the closest point
on the line
so the closest point
on the line so let's say that this is
the closest point on the line we want to
feel good that this segment connecting
them so let me do this in a new color
that the segment connecting them is
going to be perpendicular to the line
that it goes just straight down like
that that it's going to be perpendicular
and i'm going to prove this by
contradiction i'm going to assume that
it's not perpendicular so assume
assume
that the
segment
segment connecting
connecting this is kind of wordy a point
off
line
and closest point to the line
closest point
to line
line is not
is not
perpendicular to
the
line so how can i visualize that well i
could draw my line right over here so
that's line l
and
let's say i have my point o right over
here
point o and let's say the closest point
on line l 2.0 let's say that it's not so
let's say it's over here that if i were
to connect these two points that it's
not perpendicular to line l so this is
the closest point let's call this point
a and let's say that the segment
connecting these two
is not perpendicular to the line
so let me get
so
let's assume this is not perpendicular
so this angle this angle
this angle right here is not
is not 90 degrees
so if we assume that the reason why this
is going to be a proof by contradiction
is i can show that if this is not 90
degrees that i can always find a point
that is going to be closer another point
on line l that is going to be closer to
point o which contradicts the fact that
this was supposed to be the closest
point a was supposed to be the closest
point on line l to o and how do i always
find a closer point well i construct a
right triangle
i can construct a right triangle
just like this
like that
and we see that this distance let's call
this distance right over here a
unless we could call the base of this
triangle b we're just in a different
color
so a
b
if that's the base of the the right
triangle then the hypotenuse is the
distance from o to a we could call that
c
we know from the pythagorean theorem
that a squared plus b squared
plus b squared let me give this enough
plus
b squared is going to be equal to c
squared is going to be equal to c
squared
and so b squared if we have a
non-degenerate triangle right over here
this is going to be some positive value
over here and so a is going to be less
than c
so
this
gets us to the conclusion because if
this is some positive value here and a
and c are positive everything at
positive distances and this tells us
that a has to be less than c that a
non-hypotenuse side of a right triangle
of a non-degenerate right triangle
assuming it has some area is going to be
shorter than the hypotenuse the
hypotenuse is the longest side
so a
is going to be less than c
which would tell us if a is less than c
then we found another point
let's call this point i've used a lot of
letters here let's point let's call that
point d d is going to be closer
d is closer
d
is closer so we've just set up a
contradiction we assumed a was the
closest point on line l to point o but
we assumed that the segment connecting
them is not at a 90 degree angle if it's
not at a 90 degree angle then we can
drop a perpendicular and find a closer
point which fo which is a contradiction
to the fact that a was supposed to be
the closer point
so this leads to a contradiction
contradiction
contra
diction because you can actually find
this is not the closest point you can
always find a closer point so therefore
the segment connecting a point off the
line to the closest point to the line
must be perpendicular must be
perpendicular
so the segment
connecting a point off the line
to a closest point on the line that must
be perpendicular to the line must be
perpendicular to the line and just like
that we hope we hopefully feel good
about the idea that if you have a radius
and the point at which it intersects a
tangent line to the circle that that
forms a 90 degree angle the radius and
the tangent line